لربما ارتبط اسم جيوفاني فيريرو بعلامه
الشوكولاته الشهيره في الريرو لكنه ايضا
اسم كبير في عالم المال والاعمال فهو ايضا
اغنى رجل في ايطاليا وصاحب ثروه تقدر بنحو
39 مليارا وتسعمائه مليون دولار فما سر
هذه الثروه ولد جيوفاني فيريرو في ايطاليا
عام
1964 وهو العام الذي احتفل فيه والده
ميشيل فيريرو باول منتج من الشوكولاته
لماركه فيريرو الشهيره بعد ان كان قد ورث
عن والده مقهى ومخبزا بسيطا انذاك قام
ميشيل الذي لقب بملك الشوكولاته بتعديل
احد منتجات اسرته التي بدات نشاطها
التجاري في اربع نيات القرن الماضي كان
المنتج جنديا عباره عن شوكولاته ممزوجه
بالبندق تباع في وعاء زجاجي لكنه صنع منها
نسخه كريميه تحت علامه تجاريه جديده هي
نوتيلا التي حققت رواجا كبيرا لاحقا اتبع
ميشيل الذي بدا اسمه يظهر كاهم صانع
للشوكولاته سياسه سريه في الانتاج كذلك
منع التجول في مواقع التصنيع ثم بدا
بتطوير اعماله ليفتح خطوطا للبيع عالميا
في السبعينيات اطلقت الشركه منتجات جديده
كمفاجاه كيندر وهي بيضه الشوكولاته التي
تحوي العابا للاطفال وكذلك كره الشهيره
وفيما كانت شركه فيريرو تنمو شيئا فشيئا
حظيت جوفاني بفرص تعليم جيده حيث درس
بمدارس اوروبا قبل ان يتابع دراسته
الجامعيه في تخصصات التسويق والاقتصاد في
امريكا بعد الانتهاء من دراسته انضم
جوفاني للعمل في شركه العائله وكان جزءا
من نجاحاتها ثم ولاه والده مع شقيقه بيترو
منصب الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه في عام 19
مصنعا منتشرا في جميع انحاء العالم فيما
امتلك جيوفاني الذي يشتهر بانه روائي ايضا
ثروه تقدر بنحو 39 مليارا وتسعمائه مليون
دولار مع التربعه على عرش مملكه
الشوكولاته التي تجلب السعاده لمحبيها